free Wi-Fi there are no sweeter two
words in the world at least at first
sight then you come to realize you pay
for it in horrendously slow speeds you
can do it come on one kilobyte to go and
far worse in serious security threats to
your personal data but the solution to
those horrors promises to be on the way
and it starts in this futuristic
telephone booth where the speeds are so
fast you want to set up your office
right next to it New York City is teamed
up with City Bridge deployed citywide
Wi-Fi by replacing those old telephone
booths I'd like to place a collect call
with these new NYC link kiosks it's just
one example of the Wi-Fi networks
popping up across the country with new
technologies that will allow us to lean
less on pricey cellular data this
network is really fast but like any
public Wi-Fi it's not worth it unless
you take some real security precautions
thanks to the fiber gigabit connection I
got 15 times faster download speeds than
my Starbucks and eight times faster than
my home Internet it also means speedy
uploads and smooth 4k streaming but
almost better than the speed is the fact
that it uses something called pass point
sometimes called hotspot 2.0 this allows
a hotspot to work more like a cell tower
log into the network once and you can
seamlessly switch from one hotspot to
the next as you move around no need to
log in again and again
Boingo which provides most hotspots and
airports has also started to use pass
point a network this fast is going to
bring a lot of people those people will
slow down speeds but they'll also make
it a target for hackers you wouldn't use
a public toilet without the proper
precautions don't use a public hotspot
without them either number one
encryption pass point networks use wpa2
encryption still never input sensitive
information or download anything from a
website that doesn't have SSL encryption
look for HT
TPS in the web address bar and the
little padlock icon number to get a VPN
a virtual private network which creates
an encrypted tunnel for your traffic is
your safest bet if your company doesn't
provide a VPN I suggest hotspot Shield
for Windows and Android and cloak for
Mac and iPhones number 3 improve your
digital hygiene make sure your passwords
are strong and different use a password
manager like dashlane to keep track of
them setup two-factor authentication on
your important accounts - that may seem
like a royal pain in the you-know-what
but just do it I did and now those two
words free Wi-Fi truly sound a lot
better at least from where I'm sitting